comme le dit l'adage il faut rendre à
césar ce qui est à césar
mais dans le cadre de la vinaigrette il
ne s'agit pas de l'empereur romain au
salon de l'auto de montréal 50 personnes
vont déterminer leurs préférences parmi
quatre vinaigrette offert dans
l'épicerie non une végétalienne avé
césar
qu'est ce que vous aimez dans la salade
caesar sanna face à la lâcheté beau film
est comme ça va tu sais ça fait pour
tous ah oui vous avez la spécialiste la
salade césar pour de vrai alors ces
missions avec john duff moutarde de
dijon vinaigre de vin rouge ou jus de
citron ou les deux mains nues le végétal
lorsqu'on ajoute amusant et partent dans
choix j'aime la texture la vie d'un
groupe qui enveloppe les feux et puis
qui adhèrent aux feuilles comme ça
chacune des bouchers mais il est
assaisonné avec la vinaigrette la
texture onctueuse ce qui est très
intéressant
savez vous où séné a été créé au mexique
dans les années 20 par un chef italien
et apparemment il y avait plus grand
chose dans le frigo du restaurant et il
crée cette salade avec les ingrédients
qui avaient moi je perçois plus le goût
des épices des yeux
m elle est on change fait samedi les
bleus n'ont pas acquis ouais je pense
qu'avec plus de détails dans le petit
salon de naïve jacques toubon y est plus
traditionnel le goût est plus frais à
tout ça pas savoir grand-chose en fait
je pense assez puissante tribu les
leggins pas mal les ingrédients que ça
prendra un avenir est à nouveau là kraft
mais quand même déjà des éléments salée
dans les ingrédients de base dont les
anchois et le parmesan
évidemment le ciel c'est un
communicateur de savoir ça va venir eux
aussi notre salade faut se rappeler que
c'est un condiment et ça vient
assaisonner un produit qui est non
salées
[Musique]
j'ai la verte et à modou lô et lou est
un tueur à se rapproche plus du goût que
cette maison tels faits maison ouf
offre spéciale à poney greaves et
l'acidité voilà n être libre et juste un
peu de pluie
délicieux le vert c'est un produit qui
s'appelle le royaume du state aulas est
un restaurant à waterloo qui a mis sur
le marché
différents produits qu'on retrouvait
dans le restaurant dont la vinaigrette
salade césar on la retrouve pas mal
partout y pas mal les ingrédients
classiques encore une fois de nous des
graines de sésame gomme de xanthane pour
stabiliser
c'est le fun qui écrivent parmesan et
non produits de fromage ou de fond de
savoir que la vraie appellation de
fromage parmesan
[Musique]
une grimace c'est qu'est ce qu'elle est
c'est noble idéal je répondrai que lui
les vieillir trop vieilli le haut c'est
quoi ces grimaces la hausse est vraiment
pop ont cessé ce groupe il produite au
naturel
ce compte là j'en sais qu'elle est
végétalienne donc là on parle plupart
mises en plis john deux d'entre eux
trouver un moyen de remplacer l'isf
c'est bon c'est léger mais je trouve que
une petite anja un guide de pêche de
copeaux c'est vraiment différent qu'ils
font ici un petit peu trop de ville met
pas dedans de la salade ça se passe bien
je pense au prix que beaucoup de gens
ont peu apprécié cela sachant que ces
cris césar
il y manque l'oeuf le parmesan leur
choix on est loin l'avenir de saison
comme on voit la texture un peu plus
liquides à cause capa d'émulsion entre
jaune d'oeuf l'acidité et l'huile le
sondage fait par ok ah ouais ok je pense
elle est plus fine agressé la vanille
je regarde la liste des ingrédients on a
pas mal tous les ingrédients de venir à
césar celle-ci moins salée que certaines
la vinaigrette végétalienne était
tellement différente qu'elle n'a pas eu
beaucoup de votes la préférer
aujourd'hui aurait été rené secours m
merci aux buteurs et aux bouteilles pour
un gars qui aime mieux la salade la
vinaigrette je trouve que quand même
fait honneur
chacune barker
[Musique]